[MUSIC PLAYING]
ABE HASKINS: My
name is Abe Haskins.
I'm a developer
programs engineer
at Google on the Firebase team,
and I'm here with my friends
Larry and Lisa from the
Google Assistant team.
And today we're going to be
talking about building games
for mobile and audio on Google.
This is going to
be a two part talk.
So the first part is going
to be all about mobile,
building games for mobile
with Google technology.
And then the second
part is going
to be all about building
audio games on the Google
Assistant using all of our
cool technology for that.
So we're going to get
started, like I said,
with the mobile aspect of
the game or of the talk.
And we're going to dig into
building mobile games on Google
via Firebase.
To get some general idea
of who we're talking to,
how many people have
heard of Firebase,
have some idea of what it is?
All right, so about half.
That's pretty good.
We're going to talk about a
handful of different things
to make sure that everyone's
on the same page about what
Firebase is, and then
we'll talk about it
in a little more depth what
the value is in your game,
how you can use it, and
what best you can do.
So our agenda for my part of
the talk, the first half hour,
is going to be first--
what is Firebase?
What were we thinking at
Google when we made this thing?
Second, who is Firebase for?
Is it something for
small game developers?
Is it something only
for mobile developers?
Is it something
for gigantic apps?
We'll answer all
those questions?
And then third, we'll
talk about what's
happening in Firebase today,
what we've been doing recently,
what we just recently
announced, and maybe
a bit about what's upcoming.
So first off, what is Firebase?
What is Firebase
on a high level?
And I'm going to generally stay
on a fairly high level for most
of Firebase.
And the reason is that
Firebase is a very big thing.
If I wanted to go into detail
about every single feature,
we would be here
for the rest of GDC,
and there is a lot of other
cool stuff here to see.
So in a simple sense,
Firebase is a platform
to help you build your game.
It's a platform to help
you grow your player base.
And it's a platform to
help you make more money.
And what this really looks
like is this big chart
of a bunch of
different features.
These are the 15 different
Firebase features
that come together to
make this platform.
And depending on who you are,
if you are a technical engineer,
or if you are a marketing
person, or a business person,
different parts of this is
going to connect with you
in different ways.
If you're an
engineer, you're going
to say, all right,
Firebase authentication.
I have some idea
of what that is.
But you might not be as
interested in the AdWords
integration.
And this is because
Firebase as a platform
is designed to help you grow
throughout the entire life
cycle of your business.
So if you're a small
business, you're early on,
you're building your
game for the first time,
you're going to be really
interested in the development
features of Firebase.
If you're a little
farther along,
you've released the
game, you're going
to want to grow your userbase.
That's where the
growth pieces come in.
And if you're a little farther
along, you have some users,
and you want to start
making a ton of money,
that is where these earning
features are going to come in.
And we'll cover all of
these in a bit more depth.
But before that, I want to
talk a bit about the philosophy
of Firebase and what
this platform means
in terms of the mindset you get
in when you're using Firebase.
You see here, we have
all of these features
that I've talked about, all
the different elements in those
develop, grow, and earn pillars.
But in the core, we
have Firebase Analytics.
And it is the core of
this graphic, obviously.
But it is also a
core as a philosophy.
What this means is that
analytics as a concept,
knowing your users
and understanding
what they are doing, is really,
really important to building
a product people love.
But most analytics
solutions stop
short of giving you
something actionable.
You can listen to what people
are doing, and you can see,
and you can watch them,
but a lot of times
it doesn't actually result
to changes in that experience
for those users.
And that's kind of
defeating the point.
So when we were thinking
about building Firebase,
we realized that
analytics had to be
the core because all
of these features
tie back to that analytics core.
So if you're logging
in with authentication,
we should use that to
enrich our analytical data.
If you're in the growth phase
and you want to tweak things,
you should be able
to say, all right,
this audience cares
about this feature.
Let's make it more prominent
in our app for them.
If we're doing something
with Firebase notifications,
you should be able to
target those audiences
and you should be able
to create funnels and all
of these things related to
every single Firebase feature
connecting back to analytics.
And on a technical level,
that's what this analytics
in the center means.
But when we're really
thinking about it,
analytics as a
core what it means
is that your player
is your focus.
If you're building
with Firebase,
you're building
with a mindset that
says, everyday,
everything I'm building,
I'm focusing on my user.
And I am building them
an experience where
they are empowered and
they feel like the boss
because that's what
they should do.
If you are the main
player of a game,
it's an experience about you.
You're interacting
with the world,
and you might not always
be the king of that world
or in the biggest house
in the entire land.
But you know that that
experience is for you.
And Firebase lets you do that.
It lets you tailor
things, and it
lets you act on
that analytical data
that Firebase Analytics
is giving you.
Again, I can't really talk
about every single one
of these features in-depth.
It would take too much time.
But on a high level,
the categories
are important to remember.
We have features
for development,
learning and growing.
And then, any given
one of these features,
you can go jump into online
and find documentation about.
And I'll talk about some of
them in a bit more depth.
So with that more depth,
let's dig into that.
What is Firebase on
a technical level?
I've just told you
what our goal is
and when we were creating this
why we made it the way we did.
But I didn't actually
say what it was.
And what Firebase is is
both a client-side SDK
and a bunch of cloud services.
These cloud services are
a bunch of things we host
and we control.
So if you're familiar with
other cloud providers,
you may be just thinking, all
right, I go into the cloud,
and I spin up a VM.
And then I still have
to write a bunch of code
to expose this
service to my user,
to my client in
a reasonable way.
Firebase isn't like that.
There's a ton of things on
that graph that everyone needs.
Everyone needs authentication.
There are very, very
few apps in the world
that don't log in a user.
And so the fact that
people, again and again,
are rewriting authentication
code just doesn't make sense.
You have to worry
about security.
You have to worry about all
of these little facets that
just waste your time.
And I'll come back
to this in a minute,
but this is just another type
of focusing on your users,
not diverting your focus
into technical decisions,
not saying, all right,
how are we going
to secure these passwords?
You don't have to think
about that with Firebase.
Since we control the servers,
we control the communication
to the servers.
You can trust that Google is
using the best of our knowledge
to make this secure,
and safe, and scalable,
so you just don't have
to think about that.
When I say the client SDKs, I
mean a bunch of client SDKs.
These SDKs get
embedded in your game.
And as a bit of history,
when we started Firebase,
we were mostly a
web-focused company.
Way back in the day,
five, six years ago,
something like that, we started
with building JavaScript SDKs.
Over time, we released native
SDKs for Android and iOS
for people building
apps and games natively.
And just recently, last
year, we released as a beta,
our C++ and Unity SDKs.
And these have just went
into general availability.
In other words, we are
very confident they're
rock solid and
usable for you today.
So if you're interested
and you're building in C++,
or you're building in unity,
you can drop these SDKs
into your game right now and
be very confident in them.
On the cloud side, the
server infrastructure
is all powered by Google Cloud.
And Google Cloud is
Google's infrastructure
as a service tool that
lets you build out
crazy, crazy complex things.
So if you were building
a very advanced MOBA,
and everyone wanted to
come play your game,
and you had millions and
millions of users every second,
you'd probably want to
look at Google Cloud.
That's a very specific use case.
And it's something that
Firebase isn't really
looking at supporting.
There's a ton of general
things in that situation
that Firebase would
help you with.
But if you're going
really advanced, and more
specifically, really specific,
you can look at Google Cloud.
And when we were looking
at building Firebase,
we decided to build
on Google Cloud, one,
so that we can say we're
building on the things that we
expose to you-- so you can use
the exact same tools we do--
but also because
we knew it really
was a great platform,
which had the scalability
and the stability that
we wanted to bring
to you because the cloud service
doesn't have much benefit
if it's always falling over.
And we definitely did not
want that with Firebase.
So who is Firebase really for?
This concept of cloud providers
is something that, in general,
depending on who you are,
it might seem really scary.
I mean, I think in general
it's actually really scary.
People think is
it going to scale?
Is it going to grow with me?
Or am I going to hit
a point where Firebase
doesn't work for me anymore?
And this goes back to
the scalability part
of Google Cloud.
We really, really wanted
to build a solution that
would keep growing with you.
So if you were 10 people, or if
you were a company with 1,000
people, if you add 10
users or 100 million,
we wanted Firebase to be
able to keep up with you
so you wouldn't have
to be concerned.
Like I said, there are
features and situations
where if you wanted something
super, super specific,
we can help you grow
into Google Cloud.
But Firebase itself is designed
to scale incredibly, incredibly
well.
And beyond that, beyond
the technical part,
Firebase is always
for people who
want to focus on their users.
Like I said before,
this isn't just
a focus of tailoring
experiences.
Tailoring an
experience is great.
That's super
important to building
a game that connects with
people, tweaking things
and letting them experience
a game in a way that
feels all their own.
But it's also about,
as a business,
where are you
putting your focus?
At the end of the
day, as a gamer,
I don't care what cloud
provider is supporting my game.
I really don't care if it's on
AWS, if it's on Google Cloud,
if it's on any other service.
It doesn't make a difference
to me as the player.
But what does make
a difference is
how much love got put into the
experience that I'm playing.
And if you have 10 people,
you have only so much time,
and you have only so
much time to dedicate
to technical decisions.
You have only so much time
to dedicate to gameplay
and to designing an experience.
And by allowing us the ability
to control the servers,
to do all your operations, to do
all of these other things that
come with running servers,
we ensure that you do not
have to think about that.
We give you more time to
focus on your core experience.
Although none of
these things are
tools which generally
directly relate to game play,
they'll all improve it
by giving you back focus.
And that focus comes
to the user and lets
them have a really beautiful
experience in your game.
And again, we can see all
of these features, all
of these tieback analytics.
Every single one of these is
small, and understandable,
and usable, but it's
a huge, huge time sink
to do on your own.
Real-time database is a
great example of this.
So Firebase real-time
database is something
that if you have, for example,
a matchmaking system where
you just want to say, I'm
available for a match.
And anyone else can say,
I'm interested in a match,
and you can get paired up.
In general, that's a very
complicated thing to make.
That is definitely nontrivial.
And you would have to
spend a significant amount
of engineering effort building
up real-time communication
layers, and trying
to scale sockets,
and dealing with a
lot of complexity.
But with the real-time
database, you
don't have to worry about that.
You can import our client,
you can start writing data,
you can start receiving updates
to all of your other players.
And you can do
that in a way that
is just very simple,
very understandable,
and feels natural
in your environment.
That's a very important part.
We want everything
to feel natural.
So if you're building C++,
it'll feel natural, Unity,
it will feel natural
for you as a developer.
So if we add Firebase
Analytics-- which is the core,
so it's a great starting place--
to our game, this is the
code we have to write.
You'll realize it's
not a lot of code.
In fact, it is the
definition of no code.
And this is because Firebase
Analytics, by default, is so
tailored for mobile
experiences, it knows so much
about what every
mobile developer needs
and every game
developer is going
to want that we don't have
to think about forcing
you to report events.
So there's a ton of things
like opening the app,
installing the app,
doing an in-app purchase,
recording retention--
all of these things
you don't have to think about.
Just by including Firebase
Analytics in your game,
it starts recording all
of that and providing it
to you in a dashboard.
So in the simple use case, there
is no code for you to write.
You drop it in, and
you're good to go.
In a slightly more
advanced use case,
you can write a
few lines of code,
but frankly, it would
take you a lot of effort
to write a lot of
Firebase Analytics code.
It is a very succinct
SDK that lets you just
report what you need to report.
So in this case, we're adding
in a custom game event saying,
I went to this level.
I began playing it.
And we're recording the
value of that level.
So I can go back
into my Analytics,
and I can say, all right, this
person started this level five
times.
Or more interestingly,
on average,
people tried this level 22
times before they beat it.
And that's the type
of insight that's
super valuable but
incredibly, incredibly cheap.
It's one line of code to
get that into your game.
And once we get
that into our game,
we can immediately
start seeing it.
And this is one of my
favorite, favorite parts
about Firebase Analytics-- is
that in the first few seconds--
we're not waiting
days to understand
if our implementation
is correct.
We're not waiting
days to make sure all
of our analytics
events are reporting.
In the first few seconds, you
can go on your development
device, and you can start seeing
a stream of those events coming
in.
So if you're building
a game like this,
where we have that flow--
I'm recording a level select
event, level beginning,
if they completed the level.
So we can see they
restarted there.
And this is just me
testing on my device,
but this allows me to know that
all of my tooling is in there
and it's working
as I would expect.
So I'm not shipping
the game and then
finding out later that I forgot
to record this type of event
or we're missing this.
We know seconds after
we put that code
in that everything's working
great and everything's
reporting.
And the even cooler
part about this
is that you can see
those built in events.
All of that stuff that we
know you're going to want,
it's already in there, and
it showed up here, too.
So for example, over
in our top events,
we see a user engagement event.
And this is just a type of
event that Firebase Analytics
records for you automatically.
And down here, we see some
custom user properties.
And again, these are things
that Firebase Analytics is just
recording for you.
And in this case, we know
exactly when we opened our app.
So for example, I started
this at exactly 5 PM.
And we'll get information
like this, all the way
through, all
automatically reported,
up until they uninstall the app.
Hopefully, they will never
get to uninstalling your app,
but if they do, you will
have a complete view
of the lifecycle of that user.
And again, we can
obviously dive in here.
We can see more.
We can see-- this definitely
came from a Unity player
activity, so we're 100% sure
this is where it's coming from.
We get other information.
We get that level
ID that we logged.
And we can dig into
this if we want.
But this is really
for development.
This is for testing and
making sure everything
is looking great.
It's really good at that.
But we're not going to collect
a bunch of users information
in this way because if
you have a big game,
it'll just be like crazy,
crazy numbers of events.
If only we had
something that let
you look at a ton of users
kind of condensed down
into an understandable way.
Well, maybe we do.
If you go a few hours out,
you've shipped your game,
you have a good user base.
So you get a lot
of data rolling in.
We can see this other really
cool view called the Stream
View.
And this is a near
real time view
of all the data coming
into your analytics.
In this situation, we're just
showing the geographic heat
map of where everyone is
and what they're doing.
But we can already see
general trends emerging.
So we can see the majority
of players of this game
are in that section of the US.
That could be due
to the time of day,
or it could be due to whatever.
But we also see down below
how many people are currently
in our game.
In this case, it's 136.
We can see the top user
properties, so in this case,
that's just an API version.
But if you were logging
other user properties,
it could be up.
Right now the
majority of players
online are playing because they
want to know about football,
or they're playing because
they're doing this.
You can see a great
overview here.
We can also see app versions.
And if you want, I don't
have details on it,
but you can see
random user snapshots.
So you can get a view
very similar to that debug
view for just a random user.
So if you're curious
about what they're seeing
and what they're
experiencing, you
can dive into a specific user.
So once we're past, that, like
that Dashboard's really cool.
It's nice to see in real
time what people are doing
and how they're
interacting with your game.
But it's not going
to be something
that you can take and
present to a CEO-type person
or someone who really
cares about this data.
It's nice to see.
It's really cool.
It's really insightful,
and you can learn a lot.
But that's not the end result.
So after a few days of
recording information,
we get enough data,
we get to see trends.
And we get a whole
bunch of trends.
We can get a bunch of
this data, all for free.
And in this case, we're
recording everything
from in-app purchase
revenue to active users,
and retention
cohorts, information
about the device,
what OS are they on,
what version are they on.
This is all information
from your game.
This is all stuff that
our analytics package
can pick up and report
for us, which is great.
But this is kind of where
the magic of Google comes in.
And this is something that
Google is really great at.
You probably don't notice,
but Google knows a fair bit
of information about you.
We really care about
customizing our experiences
for every individual person.
And so if you go
to Google search,
it's probably different
than my Google search.
You'd never notice,
but we care a lot
about customizing
and changing things
for each individual user.
And with all this
information we have,
we thought, well,
wouldn't it be great
if we could surface some of
that into our analytics tools.
So they're not just
getting information
about what people are
doing in their game,
but they're getting a context
about who these people are.
So down here on
the bottom right,
you can see the location.
And you could maybe speculate
about how we could get location
from your game.
We could probably
guess it somehow.
But that information is actually
coming from Google's knowledge
database about these people.
So you'll get information
about where they're located.
You'll get information
about gender,
or age, or general
interest categories.
So you'll get a
bunch of information
that's not coming from
your app, but that
helps improve your view of
your players and a better
understanding because we can
enrich this with Google data.
That's one of my
favorite magical things
about Firebase Analytics.
We just get so much
cool data so cheaply,
and if you were to implement
all this in your app, everything
we've showed here, it would be
those logged Firebase events.
We do like three events
for our custom level stuff,
and all of this
comes in for free.
This is just
dropping in that SDK.
So how much is this?
This is a great question, right?
You're probably
thinking this is going
to be per user model or some
very, very expensive price tag.
Obviously, it's going
to be super expensive.
And I wouldn't put all
this dialogue into this
if it actually was
super expensive.
Firebase Analytics
is completely free.
So whether you have 10
users, or 100 million,
it's going to cost you the
same, which is nothing.
You can log as many
events as you want.
Well, there are some
restrictions on events,
but it's not because
you're not paying us.
It's just some interesting
parts of analytics.
But you can log tons
of different things.
You can report a ton
of different data.
And it is all completely free.
One of the great things, though,
as we were building Firebase
and we were thinking about how
to make Firebase Analytics as
powerful as we possibly could,
we wanted to make it clear
that every part of Firebase
was working together
and every part of Google was
working together with Firebase.
So we were thinking,
all right, we
have all of these
built-in charts.
We have all this great
data that we're showing.
But what if somebody wants
to go a step further?
What if they're using a tool
like Data Studio, or Tableau,
or any of these other
great visualization tools,
and they're used to generating
really detailed reports.
Wouldn't it be great
if you could do
that with Firebase Analytics?
And so we made it so you could.
You can export every single
event out of Firebase Analytics
directly into BigQuery.
And BigQuery is a paid service
that's part of Google Cloud.
So the Firebase Analytics
part of this is free,
but BigQuery is paid.
So you can export
every single event.
And when I say
every single event,
I literally mean
every single event.
There is not sampling
happening here.
And it's just a near real time
feed of everything everyone's
doing directly into BigQuery.
So if you want to slice that,
and you want to dice that,
and you want to
understand exactly
what every single person
in your game is doing,
you can do that with BigQuery.
And from here, like I
said, you can take it out
into a bunch of different tools.
BigQuery is mostly accessed
through a SQL-like interface,
but you can pull it out into a
bunch of different tools, all
designed specifically to deal
with big data sets like this.
Now, sadly, we're already
pretty far into this,
and we can't cover all
of Firebase Analytics,
of Firebase for sure.
But we can take a look at it.
So I want to show you a demo of
a game that actually the people
who were working on the Firebase
Unity SDK and the C++ SDK put
together.
And this is a game
called Mecha Hampster.
So let me just hop
over to my camera,
and we'll see my
fantastic phone here.
So this demo-- if I
can unlock my phone--
is a simple game.
It's a marble roller style
game, where you explore a world
and get to the end, which
is always super exciting.
And this is kind of the
cool part about Firebase--
is that this idea, this
game, isn't crazy innovative.
It's not something that
we've never seen before,
but we can make it better.
We can make it more
interactive, more social,
by putting Firebase
features in it.
So right out of the
gate, we have this option
to create an account,
sign in later.
This is Firebase authentication.
Just doing account management
in a general situation
would require servers.
It would require a fair
bit of infrastructure.
But we don't need that.
So we can go to
create an account,
and I'll quickly type a--
that's close enough at--
luckily, I'm not going to
have to go through the flow
to actually verify
this [INAUDIBLE].
It's hard to type like this.
At, nope.
Oh, is that?
That's display name.
That's my bad.
I've got a great display name.
Abe@abe.abe.
That's a real email address.
I wish.
And the password--
you can all see it.
It's hello world.
Don't log in to
mess with my scores.
Whoops.
Interesting.
WiFi must have
flickered or something.
We've got into our game.
We've just signed in with
Firebase authentication.
And we have access to the
Mecha Hamster Adventure.
Now, there's a few
components of this
that I want to walk you through.
The first one is very simple.
Let's go play a level.
And if we were building this
game in a traditional way,
we would have built
these levels beforehand.
We would have rolled them up
into the data of our game.
And we would have
shipped it out.
But with Firebase,
we have the ability
to really easily store this
information inside of Firebase.
So these levels are all stored
in the Firebase real time
database.
So as I go through
here, and I roll around,
and I try to get to the
end very, very well.
So it looks like I'm
great at this game.
I know that this level is coming
out of the real time database.
So if I wanted to add levels,
or I wanted to tweak levels,
I wouldn't have to
redeploy play this game.
I could just go out, and
I could edit these levels
in my database.
And they'll get pulled down.
Similarly, if I want
to record high scores,
I can submit the
score, upload it.
It turns out I did
not do very well,
so I only got five
seconds on there.
But this is also stored
in the real time database.
So this isn't a crazy new
idea, but it's something
that generally you
would have had to put
effort in the servers for.
You would have had to put
effort into infrastructure.
And with Firebase, you
just don't have to.
There's some other
great use cases.
So since we know
all of our levels
are stored in the
real time database,
we can go a step
further and say,
why don't we just let
people make new levels?
So we'll go into the editor,
and we'll design up a level.
It's going to say A for Abe.
Ab is close enough to Ab.
We'll put that there,
put an exit over here.
There we go.
Let's play that, make
sure that it works.
Beautiful, great level,
we'll go back to our editor.
Now we have the ability
to save, share this level,
send it around, and it's
all stored in the real time
database.
Once we get into
saving and sharing,
we start getting into other
Firebase features, though.
So Ab is going to be
the name of that map.
As soon as I upload
this, it's going
to get published to everyone
who wants to know about it.
So we're sending out
push notifications.
We won't get one on
this device, but if you
had this game installed,
you'd get a thing saying,
hey, new level has been
released on Mecha Hampster.
You can go play that.
If I want, I can click
share, and I can share it out
to a bunch of different
friends and people like that.
I sadly have no
friends on this device,
but if I had recent
contacts, they'd
be showing up down there.
Then we can just go ahead and
head back to our main level,
and we can let people
experience that gain.
So these are things-- like
I said, this isn't crazy.
It's not anything ridiculous.
It's just easier
for you, and it's
less effort for you to
maintain this game over time.
It gets taken care
of by Firebase.
And if something does go
down, if one of the servers
falls over or
anything like that,
we know that it's going
to come back to Firebase
to take care of that.
And it's just a nicer
way to build an app.
So real quick, let's just
recap what we just saw.
So we sign in with
Firebase authentication.
Obviously, no one noticed.
The player doesn't
notice that we're
using Firebase authentication.
They just know they
made an account.
They made a level.
That's great.
Then we use a real time
database to load levels,
to create a level.
We use cloud messaging to
send out push notifications
to everyone who cared.
And we used Firebase Analytics
to record all of this,
so we know what
everyone is doing.
All of this with
without servers,
all of this without
infrastructure,
and without cloud,
and everything
like that that you don't
want to think about.
All we did as a developer
is include our SDK in there,
call out to some services,
and let Firebase do its magic.
So this whole section
is who is Firebase for,
and the answer is
Firebase is for anyone,
any game, big or small.
There's always something in
here that's going to be useful.
And we looked at that
gigantic chart of all
these different features.
And what it comes down to is
that any one of those features
could be useful to you, but
in all likelihood, all of them
won't be.
You won't want to put in all
15 features into your game.
So if we're forcing you to
include a gigantic SDK you're
not going to use, it's not going
to be in your best interests.
So if you only want to use
Firebase authentication,
if you only want
to use analytics,
you can drop that in
independent of dynamic links
or remote config.
You don't have to deal with
those if you don't want to.
Obviously, you can, and they
all work better together.
But every individual
component of Firebase
is designed to be used
alone with the addition
of the Firebase core,
which is the shared bits.
So what's upcoming for Firebase?
What is next in
the Firebase world?
Well, the Firebase SDK for unity
and C++ is now officially out
of beta.
It's general availability.
It's been public
for almost a year,
but you can go out,
and download it,
and be very confident in
stability, and everything
like that.
We've spent a bunch of time
talking with game developers,
making sure this
is something that
really connects with everyone.
And besides that, there's
a bunch of crazy stuff.
But here's the thing.
Firebase is a product
that's always growing.
We're always working
on cool new things
because we're working towards
this idea of this platform
where you will never have
to deal with servers.
We just don't want you to
have to think about it.
So since Firebase SDK for unity
and for C++ is relatively new--
it's just coming into
general availability--
this is a fantastic time to dive
in and give us your feedback.
We're still shaping
Firebase today,
and we want your feedback,
from game developers
specifically, to know how we
can make this amazing for you.
We think it's amazing.
But we want to know.
And we want to know
what else we can do.
So if you're interested
in this at all,
even if you're
thinking, well, I'm
not quite sure this is
perfect for me, go dive in.
And please, you can
email me, tweet at me,
I'll make sure it gets
directly to the team who
is working on it, so
we can really, really
make it something that
works great for you.
So with that, I'm
pretty much out of time
at exactly 30 minutes.
I'm going to hand it
over to Lisa and Harry
to talk about audio-based games.
Thanks for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]